I'm hopefully I wait let's explain we do
a question for the internet News
answering unhelpful advice with Bobby
kilala at Dante Cheng hey guys this
question is for an helpful advice
recently I have become friends with this
woman
it started over coffee led to a movie
date then some wine at my apartment and
then we have sex it was amazing this
woman is 37 and I'm 23 we've been seeing
dating now for almost a month and it's
been a really great experience for so
long I felt every girl I did it had
something to always be insecure about
stuck-up or immature I really feel like
I finally met someone who almost
perfectly meshes with me it was almost
too good to be true she feels the same
way this woman has been married before
her husband passed she has four kids and
we have the huge age gap we're
absolutely crazy about each other more
on her and it feels while I'm slow with
my emotions cuz the fear of getting hurt
due to my bad past with relationships
very long indeed but my main question is
do I go for it my family is Native
American and I know they would not
approve of her because of the age gap
and children how do you approach
something like this to family any help
would be great feeling stuck in my
situation love you guys 37 the woman had
four kids he's 22 23 yeah well this is a
tough one if it's love if it really is
love then that that just transcends but
if it's a fetish on either end then
that's a little weird
that's fleeting then in a year you'll be
sick of each other yeah on to the next
cougar yeah it could be even from her
end like yeah I got some young dick
that's a lot of baggage man
that is true yeah just marrying her
you're marrying to get your basically
your kids and it's all it's all fun and
games in the beginning when you're just
[ __ ] her and she's not bringing the
kids around but you have to think about
the long run and how you're gonna be
living in a household with four children
and playing that being that father role
essentially that's that's a lot for a 23
year old you have a lot of life to live
and you're 20 should be spent exploring
many different types of women and/or men
or you know what I mean like that's such
a pivotal part of a young man
yeah I think I agree with you baby um
but like I said you know there are you
know instances where like you said if
it's love it's love and there's it
sometimes it just works out yeah or just
take it one moment at a time you can't a
lot of it it's like I'm gonna project
into the future and go what this happens
this happens that my parents doesn't you
know just live in the moment just take
it one day at a time and see how it
feels like you can't you're putting your
whole life into one moment and then
that's then exactly if you're looking
too far into the future that's also a
mistake you know it yeah my field day he
might feel differently tomorrow yeah
what's the oldest chick you ever had a
hooker what cocaine 27:55 I thought
today was 55 not too bad she was 55 he's
55 and he's early 27 no 55 is Golden
Girls
no that's Julie Roberts but not Julia
Roberts
no shoot it was actually here she was
Japanese and white oh then she's like 60
look 16 you have anything to plug comedy
pop-up you sponsor me know what's it
called the completely unprofessional but
completely unprofessional podcast